uh we uh did you see what hap
okay so let's just play this video
i'm sure this is all over the place does
this do you know what this is
i've i heard of it i didn't see it okay
well this she went viral
um for putting uh well
how about we just play the video sure
okay
hey y'all for those of y'all that know
me know
my hair has been like this for about a
month now it's not by choice
no it's not a choice
when i do my hair i like to you know
finish it off with a little got the big
glue spray
you know just to keep it in place well i
didn't have anymore can you translate
for me mike you speak hood i
i don't know what she's so she's saying
her hair has been like this for a month
oh they're sometimes frozen
and she's saying that she used to use uh
got to be glue which has got to be as a
brand of hair
product thank you um and and then i that
that's all i got so okay
okay well i didn't have any more that to
be displaced so i use this
for those that are listening via podcast
that is a spray can of
gorilla glue which by the way i highly
underestimated gorilla glue i don't like
gorilla glue
like even when i was doing the foam
padding at my place in my studio
it i didn't realize that gorilla glue
i thought it was just weak because
things kept falling off and then i
realized gorilla glue you have to
actually apply pressure and hold it for
whatever i don't know how the spray
works but the glue itself but once i
figured out how
gorilla glue works it's unbelievably
[ __ ]
crazy how that [ __ ] sticks like it's
it's
it's bad dude i didn't know they made a
spray though that's [ __ ] crazy
gorilla glue she's [ __ ]
bad idea yo look
my health it don't move you hear what
i'm telling you
i mean so it worked it's gonna fall out
i mean
well i have a i'll have you know that i
have a follow-up don't worry
oh no that's not good i know it's not
great
that's not good
i've washed my hair 15
times and it don't move
stiff wear whoa
not him so i'm gonna tell y'all like
this if you
ever ever run out of got to be glue
spray
don't ever ever use this well i
don't think why would you use that
who would use that gorilla glue had to
put out a tweet
hi there we're sorry to learn about your
experience we do not recommend using our
products in hair as they are considered
permanent
you can try soaking the affected area in
warm soapy water or applying rubbing
alcohol to the area
now
[Music]
was
was the reason she used the gorilla glue
i'm not going to say i didn't say it i
didn't i
i'm watching you i am watching you like
a hawk but i didn't say it
but i'm watching but believe me i
[ __ ] thought it
okay i think we all thought it
i think we all thought it
by the way a lot of people don't know
what the original plan to name for
gorilla glue was
uh what was that mike
okay yeah that's what i thought i wanted
to just get that out of my sister no
it needed to happen it was like one of
those old products from the 18 something
and then they had to change it
like i don't know and they go are you
sure this is more or less offensive
yeah like that there actually was and
this isn't me making a joke there was
something called like tar baby soap that
was a real thing
look it up uh there's that uh civil
rights museum that actually has all of
the old products for real
and they go like and the guy goes sir
are you sure we should be calling it
this and he goes what do you want to do
crazy glue's taken
super glue's taken yeah
loctite's taken loctite's the worst i
think
have you ever used loctite i've never
used loctite it's bro
when i when i tell you it's one of the
only glues that i constantly get on me
when i'm using it because
you want to talk about an instant
industrial strength [ __ ] at ease i
mean
the minute it acts it touches oxygen
it's like [ __ ] diamond hard it's
crazy
this is her trying to show that she
can't take it off
i gotta be honest with you though this
chick is handling it
way better than anybody else would any
other people
no look yo look
look you wipe it off and nothing happens
they said soak it you dumb
didn't soak it that i'm living at this
moment yeah but you did this to yourself
because you're an idiot the life that i
guess i'm happy
i want to feel bad for you i really do i
really do want to feel
i feel kind of bad but there's a limit
there's certainly a limit to how bad i'm
gonna feel about the situation
uh well it turns out women who went
viral for using gorilla glue and hair
gets treatment at a hospital
that's going to leave a mark a louisiana
woman went viral last week for using
gorilla glue in place of actual
hairspray
before finally checking into the
hospital on saturday to get her hardened
adhesive removed according to posts on
her instagram
the woman identified in the news reports
as tasika brown
posted on february 14th beautiful name
that was my grandmother's name
it's lovely it's a lovely name yeah
what's where's it
is that dutch yeah what is that what's
the uh
what's the uh uh origins of that word
norway
it's a norwegian word actually people
know that um
somebody said nine thousand dollar
gofundme look i get it whatever i'm just
happy a black person has a gofundme and
they're making money and it's not about
how white people did something to them
so
let her have the money i don't even care
about gofundme scams as long as she's
not trying to start a [ __ ] race war
for nine grand
let her have her nine grand the woman
identified as tasika brown
posted was she's you know what she's
named after the [ __ ] she's named
after a
the inf an infinity stone from marvel
sorry
yeah but vader built films in the chat
says toseka compensation now
uh posted on february 4th that her hair
had been stuck in place for a month
after she ran out of her usual hair
product and opted to use gorilla glue
instead look
my hair don't move i already read that
uh on saturday
brown posted two photos one of herself
sprawled on a hospital bed
and another of an emergency room
entrance to saint bernard's parish
hospital
in louisiana her decision to seek
medical uh treatment came
after three days of crowdsourcing
potential solutions including from the
maker of gorilla glue the company told
tmz that brown could use rubbing alcohol
in her head but warned that if
it had actually been in place for a
month it was likely it's likely
fractured at the root
which means that they might have done
they might have dealt with something
like this before
oh lady come on man
i i've i've uh i don't know man i've
seen some questionable products be used
but
i mean jesus gorilla glue spray
i i can't even imagine how that started
feeling when it started hardening